[Musica]
[Applauso]
ma la sera spesso una delle domande che
mi fanno è qual è la mia fotografia
preferita quella più forte quella più
bella
io correggo quelle necessarie per molto
tempo ho cercato
di narrare condividere alcune delle foto
che sono più legato poi ho cambiato ho
cercato di non raccontarle più ho anche
smesso forse un po di mentirmi quindi ho
iniziato a parlare delle fotografie
quelle più dolorose quelle non fatte le
fotografie dove arrivi troppo tardi dove
l'unica cosa da fotografare una barca
con l'assenza delle persone l'odore
della benzina o qualche il corpo da
recuperare
il piccolo ha nei fatti
[Musica]
mi chiamo francesco una volta sono un
fotografo se preferite un
fotogiornalista e oggi cercherò
attraverso le mie fotografie di
raccontare alcune storie
in realtà io sono un mezzo e quindi dico
sempre che le storie o meglio quelle
foto non appartengono me ma appartengono
alla persone fotografate
l'etica giornalistica ci impone di
raccontare sempre la verità di nel mio
caso da fotografo di dire esattamente
cosa c'è all'interno di una fotografia è
facile comunque guardare all'interno di
una fotografia perché basta comunque
osservare i dettagli per un fotografo a
volte la scelta è semplicemente che
decide cosa fotografare è molto più
complicato invece narrare raccontare
cosa non c'è dietro una fotografia cosa
non c'è nella fotografia
della narrazione soprattutto dei flussi
migratori dei popoli in movimento dei
profughi si è sempre concentrare uno
spazio temporale che va dalla barca in
difficoltà dal raggio con le vittime
quindi numeri dal suo corso dallo sbarco
nel porto e dalle polemiche non c'è mai
un prima non c'è mai un dopo la mia
responsabilità quindi qual è quella di
raccontarle
raccontarle con delle storie cercare di
entrare nei particolari
ecco perché oggi abbiamo scelto se
fotografie una volta una gallerista mi
ha detto ma non sono belle però in
quelle fotografie io ho trovato una
forza incredibile che adesso
naturalmente cercheremo di osservarle
insieme la prima fotografia e l'isola di
lesmo 2015
questa giovane mamma siriana
a distanza vedo che stava con una
cassetta di polisterolo quella del pesce
e del nastro non riuscivo a credere a
quello che naturalmente la mia macchina
fotografica inizialmente mi faccio a
vedere mi sono avvicinato ed era
esattamente quello che pensavo una madre
che non trovando più giubbotti di
salvataggio in turchia ha deciso di
costruire un giubbotto la sua piccola
con delle cassette del nastro sono
qualcosa che una mamma può fare se
guardate ancora più in profondità in
questa foto
l'unica parte che era interessante di
tutto quello che c'era da fotografare
vedete la delicatezza in cui la mamma
avvolge il nastro in cui la bambina
viene la mamma paura della perdita e il
fratello che dà una mano dall'altra
parte questa bambina probabilmente nei
suoi anni trascorsi non ha mai avuto dei
compagni di scuola se non all'interno
dei campi di transito prima di arrivare
in grecia
la seconda foto invece fatta nel 2016
era a bordo di una nave una giornata
molto particolare particolare sia per il
numero delle persone salvate quasi mille
sia purtroppo per i corpi recuperati 22
quando si recupero dei corpi il viaggio
di ritorno verso un porto è sempre
complicato e complicato perché
a bordo spessissimo ci sono dei parenti
ed è un dolore che non vivono solo loro
ma vive l'intero equipaggio e anche chi
nel mio caso e di per documentare
comunque ne prende quel dolore o
spessissimo è capitato su barche molto
più piccole di riposare pochissimi
minuti ea fianco al mio blog la
finestrina dove si affaccia sul mare la
parte sotto con dei sacchi con dei
cadaveri spesso di bambine bambini donne
uomini di cui non si conosce la storia e
la storia non ci racconterà mai nulla di
loro in questo caso mi sono soffermato
con lo sguardo verso questo ragazzo un
sopravvissuto un fortunato un rinato e
il particolare non sono solo i suoi
occhi persi nel vuoto ma quel numero che
aveva scritto prima della partenza dalla
libia da contattare in caso di morte un
numero di telefono di parenti da
chiamare per dire suo figlio il suo
compagno suo fratello è morto
è capitato altre volte durante
l'ispezione cadaveri nei porti
soprattutto siciliani erano fogli di
carta dove i numeri hanno completamente
illeggibile perché la quale aveva
rovinato
la terza foto in realtà
è una foto fatta sempre sull'isola di
lesmo nel 2015 in questo caso che non ho
fatto nessuna domanda alla famiglia sono
rimasto anche abbastanza distante ho
utilizzato una un obiettivo una lunga
lente
era troppo intima allora ha immaginato
la storia e se è vero che noi
giornalisti dobbiamo dire sempre la
verità io sono sicuro che questa storia
che mi sono immaginato e quella reale
questo padre sbarcato sull'isola di
lesbo a un certo punto crolla e scoppia
in un pianto
incredibile dove arriva alla sua piccola
non fa altro che accrescere il volto del
papa cercando di incoraggiarli io mi
sono immaginato questo papa che ha
portato via dalla siria bombardata
questa piccola con la sua famiglia ea un
certo punto dopo averla protetta per
tutto quello che viaggi lungo viaggio il
viaggio con si parla mai arrivato in
grecia è crollato è crollato perché
comunque aveva dato vita
rinascita alla sua famiglia
l'altra foto invece di cui non si parla
mai sono le cause se c'è una migrazione
perché ci sono delle cause quel primo è
quel dopo in questo caso ma in burkina
faso tre anni fa e avevo necessità
anch'io discendere all'interno di questi
buchi fino a 20 metri sotto terra sono
delle miniere informare circa 400 in
burkina faso dove ci sono questi
ragazzini che cercano delle pietre per
poi tirare su ogni cinque sacchi uno
ball gruppo ma il rischio è troppo di
non trovare oro allora loro barattano
neanche con i due dollari al giorno ma
con del riso il buco dove sono entrato
era 70 centimetri per 70 per un
fotografo è necessario avere tanto
attrezzature io dovuto scegliere strumm
macchina fotografica e un obiettivo
quel loro e poi alla fine arriva dalle
400 mila informale fa un giro
stranissimo all'interno del burkina faso
di
reciclaggio per poi passare nelle
miniere ufficiale e finisce sulla nostra
pelle nei nostri orecchini nei nostri
bracciali nelle nostre cinture tutto
quello che comunque può servire per quel
materiale
l'altra foto invece una foto del 2011 è
una foto dove questo giovane ragazzo che
non ha voluto dichiarare per motivi di
sicurezza il luogo di provenienza
probabilmente ogni geriani
a devo una vita ci ha raccontato la sua
storia una volta sbarcato sull'isola di
lampedusa con altri 250
aveva una vita normale aveva una vita
anzi tutte che normale dei soldi un
ottimo posto di lavoro una vita sociale
importante proprio perché in quei paesi
molti paesi la dittatura i diritti umani
cambiano velocemente
lui ha sentito il pericolo quindi ha
deciso di fare il viaggio verso la libia
naturalmente ha pagato i trafficanti
velocemente ha dato il doppio per
cercare di arrivare in libia c'era
gheddati come dice in fuga è riuscita ad
arrivare a lampedusa lui già sapeva di
essere inserito all'interno del centro
di accoglienza e di ricevere la tuta che
davano a tutte lui ha voluto portare
questo messaggio di dignità la foto
naturalmente poi stata utilizzata da una
ricerca da un ricercatore inglese dove
hanno hanno trasformato su una barca 250
persone in giacca e cravatta e gli
intervistati venendo 250 persone giacche
e cravatta avevano meno paura se
escludiamo lui della barca
ultima foto e qui c'è pochissimo da
raccontare sono
arrivato uno dei primi il 3 ottobre nel
2013 a lampedusa dove morirono 300
otto persone
in questo caso ci arrivò a disposizione
che nessun fotografo e giornalista
poteva entrare all'interno dell'hangar
dell'aeroporto poi grazie a delle
pressioni non solo nazionale e
internazionale ci hanno fatto entrare e
lì che per la prima volta
l'opinione pubblica ha visto 368 bare in
fila e non solo numeri la prima volta
che veniva dato alla stampa
internazionale e mondiale
la visibilità che di cosa significa
trovare delle persone morta all'interno
di un hangar al nono giorno recuperarono
da 300 68esima vittima con ancora il
feto attaccato 47 metri di profondità
allora qui il mio obiettivo da fotografo
usato il termine era uno fare entrare
più bare è possibile all'interno di
quella fotografia
per raccontarla e raccontare anche le
storie poi dei sopravvissuti che ho
incontrati ho incontrato poi
successivamente negli anni
beh l'impatto della fotografia e la
responsabilità di un fotografo è molto
importante
basta pensare
alla morte di alan curdi sulla spiaggia
di bodrum nel 2015
beh quella sofferenza quella foto
sofferta fatta da una fotografa turca
che si è fatta delle domande
pubblicarono un po obbligarla a in
pratica dato il via da parte della
germania all'apertura di un corridoio
per oltre mezzo milione di persone
la gente che transitava dalla grecia
verso la germania tra il 2015 e 2016
ogni confine era lì ringraziando la
germania e la merkel
è anche vero ritornando alla
responsabilità delle fotografie che la
maggior parte delle fotografie purtroppo
cari non si social o sui giornali né
telegiornali non son fatti da
professione e questo è un grandissimo
problema
perché è un professionista io ogni volta
che faccio una foto ogni volta che
seleziona soprattutto una foto deciso di
condividerla con il mio committente o
anche su un social mi chiedo se ha senso
pubblicare quella foto se rispetto la
dignità di quella persona
se quella foto può cambiare qualcosa o
meno soprattutto se si tratta di corpi
faccio molta attenzione non prende degli
elementi che possono comunque portare la
notizia della morte a un parente
dall'altra parte del mondo che non sa
neanche che suo figlio la sua figlia ha
intrapreso un viaggio
e quindi di naturalmente la necessità el
attenzione
la sofferenza delle mie foto io so che
le mie foto sono carichi di insofferenza
però oggi credo anche un po le vostre mi
chiamo francesco sono un fotografo e da
moltissimi anni io non faccio più il
bagno grazie
[Applauso]